I am pretty convinced that we are in the
last
stages
of
[Music]
of the ability for America to survive
we are in an end game right now and that
is not a liberal end game or a
conservative end game
a combination of both and we are
without Mercy
and we are without forgiveness
and we have to
we have to rethink that we have to get
it back into the earliest years
of public schools so that your your
civic education is complete
by High School graduation
it has nothing to do with college or
university
and the more you explore that
the more you'll see why that's simple
and common sensical
if I'm not mistaken I think in 2015 you
were spotted at the back of a Ted Cruz
Rally or something like that and and
people started calling you all these
all of these awful names and you're a
crazy right-winger and you know all of
this stuff and I I remember seeing that
I think on YouTube or something thinking
I didn't know anything about your
politics beforehand it didn't matter to
me you're a great actor I happen to you
know now I really like Ted Cruz I didn't
like him as much at the moment but okay
you were just in the back of the room if
I can picture the video again
um but that a certain side went crazy on
you but had it been the other way around
had you shown up to say a Hillary
Clinton rally I don't know that you
would have got hate that it's not
exactly equal I get the idea of that you
want to be above the craziness but right
now it does seem to me and I wrote my
whole first book was a defense of
liberalism of Classical liberalism uh it
does seem to me there is an asymmetry
that we're all struggling with right now
in terms of how each side behaves not to
say that the conservatives don't have
their Bad actors too
I think
I think if you can start out by thinking
that one side is inherently better than
the other
um more easy to perceive the morality of
the GOP as opposed to the Democrats then
you're nuts
because they're all equally nuts
the Democrats are and the so are the
Republicans and what happened in that
year was that I simply went to the
Republican caucus in Iowa
to watch
and it was you crazy radical
and then yeah
and it was
um what's his name the guy that you
mentioned look at that group Justin
no no not Ted Cruz it wasn't Ted Cruz
who was it
no it was a
was it Rubio who was no it wasn't a
candidate he was a a columnist a
commentator
and he you just mentioned him at the
beginning of the interview
um uh he outed me okay he outed me he
did he wrote a column about what was
Richard Dreyfus doing at the Iowa
caucuses and then the Liberals went
crazy
and all of my friends and right it's
just couldn't leave it alone and my son
who was that time was quite Young
he wrote
a piece that was on the internet
where he was saying why is my actor
father
in a position to give lessons in ethics
to America
and
and so what's her name uh Megan Kelly
invited us on her show when she was
still with fox
so we the two of us went on
and for me it was simply
if you're a smart person
you
scrutinize you read everything you don't
read you what what reinforces your
already assumed habits
and you know I I hold
being a high school history teacher to
be just about second to being an actor
an actor is the best thing on earth to
do
unless you're a high school history
teacher and then I would say how many
kids here in this room
have the same Politics as their parents
and whatever number of hands goes up I
say for this semester you take the
opposite View
under compulsion you do not agree with
your parents and I don't care
I want you to disagree with your parents
on everything I really love this
well it never happened so I never got to
know
and and I
I watched
I I graduated in 65.
by 69
there were kids who had the legal right
to get up and leave any class that they
just disagreed with
well
that's stupid
that's a stupid thing to do you don't
turn over the future of your country to
people who are making life decisions
when they're 16 and a half
no
in retrospect not knowing that with the
16 and a half year olds were doing you
know in 69 now these people are running
the country I mean I guess this isn't
shocking where we're at huh
no it isn't
you're right because what happened was
that it was the generation that that
took power after the 60s
they were the 70 70 to 72 school board
members they're the ones who thought
that they were smart enough to tell the
founding fathers to take a hike
and not educate
you know we we came up with a unique
system
and it was unique
and and we said we will educate you to
this system
and then you are obligated to pass it on
to your kids
and that was serious business
and we did that and that didn't
guarantee a republican future or a
Democratic future it
said that both sides had something to
offer
and if you did for instance I would
always say as as a history buff
I would say there's no such thing as one
great history
is always at least two
can you know oppose one another
and if you don't see the
advantage to the
SE to slow down and shut up
and listen more
are you hopeful that we'll get there
I am pretty convinced that we are in the
last
stages
of
[Music]
of the ability for America to survive
we are in an end game right now and that
is not a liberal end game or a
conservative end game
the combination of both and we are
without Mercy
and we are without forgiveness
and we have to
we have to rethink that we have to get
it back into the earliest years
of public schools so that your your
acidic education is complete
by High School graduation it has nothing
to do with college or university
and the more you explore that
the more you'll see why that's simple
and commonsensical
and
the founders knew
everyone had to be educated to a certain
kind of participatory citizenship
and they knew that
it had nothing to do with those who
could afford to go on to University
that was creating exactly what that why
they had left the British Empire
so
if they had some
informed Pride
there they should be as proud as punch
to give their youngest of their young
a real grounding in
civics
so it's interesting because I I talk
about a lot on the show how we are at
this moment where you're describing as
an end game we seem to be at a moment in
the country where we can basically go
two ways at this point we can either
figure out how to you know maintain
ourselves as the United States of
America or the states really just kind
of need to go their separate ways and
that's sort of what Federalism is about
in the first place but then what makes
us United and will we end up in
Perpetual Civil War and you know there's
a Litany of problems with that so
describe what what endgame I mean
endgame can go two ways Right End Game
can be we end up in just utter chaos or
there is something that comes after end
game that's positive right
um
let me hopefully I suppose
if you believe that you have to
find that which we share
and not that which we which divides us
we should be proud of
opposing views we should be proud of
having dissent
and they have always been the Hallmarks
of America always until so recently that
people don't understand what history
itself is
but that's what you've got to fight you
don't have a choice between having the
United States and having chaos
because that's not a choice that's
it may be fatal it may be the worst
possible thing that could happen to us
but what we should be doing is agreeing
on the need for civics if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell